では よろしくお願いします
えーと あの 人間の能力というものに
あの潜むでしたっけ？まあ
神秘について語る話で
そういうわけで まあ能力ということは可能性という単語にまあ入れ替えたんです
まあ大体あの 同じ意味だと思います
まあ能力というよりは可能性の方が少々明るいタイトルだと思います
なぜならば中身は暗いんだから
まあタイトルだけでも明るくしておかないと
まあよくある文句っていうのは
まあ能力っていうのはなかなか向上しないということですね
まあ人生っていうのはあらゆる困難に満ちていて
まあそれはもう今日のテーマなんですね
なかなか我々の能力は向上しない
生きてみると 仕事をしてみると
まあ困難ばっかりで どうすればいいかっていうことに
まあ仏教の立場から説明したいと思います
まず我々が勉強するのは
この これ性格ですね なんで能力は向上しないのかということで
この性格について少々喋りたいと思ってます
別にまあ 自分の他人の性格を理解することは役に立つかもしれません
ということで ちょっと曖昧なんですね
で 人の性格を知って役に立つか足さないかということもね
そんなにはっきりはしないんです
では 役に立つ可能性はあるんです
しかし 今日こちら書いてないんですけど
口で言いますけど 我々というのはすごいもう質が悪くて
人の性格はよく知りたくなるんですね
で 偉そうに知ったふりもしますよ
とにかく人に対して あの人はこういう私は知ってますよとかね
すごく判断して その相手に対してすごい無礼
侮辱に対応するんです
たとえ誤解しま 勝手に相手の性格を判断して
あの人はこういう人やと思って
その人のために親切にやっても
それは侮辱なんですね
なぜならば もう勝手に判断した性格はそうじゃないんだからね
それって人間のものすごく嫌な性格なんです
すぐ真っ先に人は何人ですかと
性格を判断したいんですね
だから何様のつもりでしょうかと聞きたいんですけど
だから人間関係はゴチャゴチャになってるんですよ
人間対親切さっていうのは片片もない
自分が神様のつもりで
あの人はこういう性格
この人はこういう性格
ですから私は  そういうふうな
まあ性格を勝手に判断しようとする
だから私はそれを曖昧で書いたんですよ
我々はなんで人の性格をそんなに知りたがるのかというと
まずその人を支配したいんですね
とんでもない罪なんですよ
この相手を支配したい気持ちがあるならば
もう人間らしからんですよ
我々にはたとえ動物さえも支配できないんです
生命は独立してあって自由なんです
それはわからないで まあ私の家来にしてやると
まあ支配管理したいんですよ
支配管理できると思っているところで世界が狂ってるんです
だからどこに誰かが人を支配しよう
管理しようと思っちゃうと
必ず失敗するんです できるわけじゃないんです
我々の心は自由に行動したいんです
ですから 自由に行動したいものに自由を与えなきゃ
いきなり野生の動物をいきなり家に飼ってしまえばどうなるんですかね
うまくいくわけないでしょうに
野生の熊でもね 麻酔銃で麻酔かけて家に運んでもらって
それから目が覚めると家にいるんだから親切にやってくると思いますかね
だからそれをまず覚えてほしいんです
それは序論で もうスライドに書いてないんです
スライドはもっと丁寧にいくんです
これは本当に丁寧な話じゃないんです
なぜ我々は人間関係をダメになっているのかというと
とにかく相手を支配したい
支配したいと なんでそんなにも人を支配したくなるんですかね
それできなくなっちゃうと
犬か猫か飼っちゃうんですね
それで支配してるつもりなんですけど
支配されてるだけで その場合は
まあ動物は喋れませんからね
自分の言うことを全部やってくれると勘違いしています
ちょこっとあの瞑想でこの心を理解する技があるんですよ
それでどんな生命でも心を理解できるようになったらね
もう我々の話になります
全然気にしてないというね
飼ってる飼い主のこと
ですから この性格を理解した方がなんとなく役に立つかもしれませんとかいうのは
そういうわけで この支配したいと思ったならば役に立ちません
最悪になるだけ なおさら問題作るだけ
しかし 仏教では性格分析はします
性格を理解できるように
すごく細かく書かれてあります
それは人を導くためなんです
人の弱いところを直してあげて
人を独立させるためなんです
自由にしてあげるためなんです
自由になりたい気持ちはあるんだけど
自由になれないんですね
それでまああなたならこう言って
こういう風に こういう風に
こういう風にした方がいいんじゃないんでしょうかと教えてあげると
本人がそれをやってみたら
どんどん自分の心が綺麗になって自由になっていくんですよ
それでその人の役に立ちます
それで自由になった人は
あの人によくアドバイスしてくれまして
ありがとうという感謝の気持ちはその時は生まれてくるんです
ですから 仏教でこの性格について語るのは
俗世間の目的と全く違う
それだけ覚えておいてください
だから何か今日何かのポイントだけでも取って言ってやるぞと思っても取れないかもしれません
会社で部下をこれで管理してやるぞとかね
できないかもしれません
慈しみさえあれば 人を育ててあげたい
人にできないことを教えてあげたい
人を幸福にしてあげたいという
全くこの無欲というんですか
見返りを期待しない人間であるならば
これは役に立ちます では
皆様は自分で判断してください
これは人の他人の生命に対する判断の種です
性格っていうのは この
判断の一種です  判断の一種です
我々が知っている性格っていうのは
我々の判断の一種ですね
人のことを判断するんです
基準は我々が作るものです
では 判断するために判断基準が必要でしょうね
これが 私たち勝手に作るんです
そこで私に勝手な判断基準があって
私の勝手な判断基準で相手のことを判断するんです
で 私はある人は怠け者だと判断する
しかし 別別の人は自分の基準で頑張り屋さんだと判断する可能性はあるでしょうに
だから 俗世間である性格判断というのは
自分の主観で自分が作った価値観セットの中で人を判断することなんです
我々の価値観によるものです
ある環境で悪い性格だとレッテルを貼られる
貼られた人は別な環境で良い性格だと認められることはよくあります
まあ例えばもう学校で教室の中で全然勉強に興味ない子は
もう先生には悪い性格だとレッテルを貼られるんですよ
そこで仲間 不良者の仲間に入ったら
こいつはとってもいい子やとそっち側で判断されるでしょうに
だから人間っていうのは
いいと判断されるところに行ってしまっちゃうんですね
だから この不良の仲間が自分の基準でよく不良やってくれますから
いい性格だと判断して
先生は悪い性格だと判断したりしているということはよくあることです
人間も他の生命も互いに異なっている
次のこの性格があるという
で 今まで説明したのは
皆様方の性格判断というのはろくでもないものであるという
ずいぶん勝手でしょうと
いい加減にしないのかという結論なんです
だって先生が悪いと判断する人は別なところでいいと判断されるし
で わからないでしょうに
性格っていうのはだからでないわけじゃないんです
性格っていうのはあるんです
そのそれを発見しなくちゃいけないんだよ
自分の勝手に見るんじゃなくて
その性格あるということには
一番いい証拠っていうのは
人間だけではなくて すべての生命がそれぞれ違うんですよ
全く似ている生命二人はいません
我々にわからないだけで
例えばアリに1匹見たら
あ 似てるんだ 似てないんですよ
我々に見えるのは体だけだから
体は見てはみてもわからないかもしれませんが
ぴったし似ていて しかし
アリ2匹にしたっても性格は違うんです
というか 互い違うんです
この互いに違うところが性格ということなんです
例えば私なら 私と似ている人っていうのは一人もこの存在の中にいません
それ 誰とも違ったところが私の性格なんです
では判断できるんですかね
そう簡単に判断できないんですよ
まあたまに体だけ似ている場合もあるが
それぞれ生命の性格が違うというのです
それでは 私と他人がどのように違いますかと発見する必要があります
だから 他人に生命判断というか
性格判断してもらうんじゃなくて
自分が一切の生命と比較してみると
どこらへん違いますかと
違うんですよ 一人しかいないんだから
ものすごい寂しいんです
仲間がいないんです それでどういうところ違いますかと
自分で自分のことを観察するしかないんです
体の違いについてちょこっと考えても
それはあまり難しいポイントじゃないんだからね
これは決して問題にしてはならないんですよ
体違うんじゃないかと
それは問題にしないでください
妹さんと私は違いも体違いますよと
その当たり前のことで個人差をつけるんじゃないんです
妹さんが体重私よりは低いんだよとかね
やっぱり性格違いますよと
それは話になりません
醜い民主差別いじめになります
そこで我々はどーんとすごい形見て判断するんですよ
自分に気に入らない体だったら
あの人性格が悪いと 嫌な人はといじめるんですよ
こういう世の中にも差別だらけでしょう
ものすごい差別 だからこの
すごく醜いんですよ まあこの間ももう今日のニュース見てないんですけど
マドンナさんがね 黒人の子供が養子にしたんだからといって
イギリス人やら人権権利団体たちがすごく怒っても裁判起こしてるんですよ
これは違法だからやめなさいと
で どうも理解できなくて
いろいろ読んでみたりすると
チラッと裏でやめるんですね
これは明らかに黒人だから馬鹿にしてるだけ
黒人のちっちゃな子供だから
病気ですごい大変な状態の子供でした
ですけど で 世界にまた教えてやるぞと
このあのヒューマンライツというのはイギリスですから
本部本部本部は しかし
それぞれ体は違います
当然体が違いますよ 物質的に見ても別々だからね
だから体に差があるのは当たり前で
それは決して判断に使ってはいけないんですよ
足がちょっと短いとか
髪の毛が薄いとか そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
歯並びが悪いとか 皮膚の色がちょこちょこと違うとか
そんなものを見ると生命見えなくなっちゃうんですよ
なんで若い人 例えばこのもうダイエット食品やらもうもう痩せる食品もいろいろ
健康 体力 あんだかんだいろんなもの
テレビでももうBSというのは見るもんじゃないんですよ
全部コマーシャルというかばっかりで一つ番組がないんです
で よく出すのは若者なんですね
若者は 1週間ぐらい食えないでいると
もうどうせ痩せますよ
5 6 キロぐらいは それでおじいさん
おばあさんたちがね あの食べ物を取ったり
高いお金出しても全然体重は変わりません
で なんでそうなっているのかとか
なんで年寄りをなんか邪魔扱いするのかとか
とんでもないことなんですよ
人は体 肉体は年取ってあっても人は人だから
この人を見るべきなんでしょうね
80歳になっても自分の母親
自分の母親なんです 親と子の間にある感情というか
関係というのはそのままなんです
小さい時はさんざんお世話になって
母親が老けて自分がどうにしようてもうるさいと
追い払うんですね そういうことっていうのは
まあ大体体中心に世の中生きてるんだからそうなるんです
で 心中心に見てみれば
寝たきりになっても自分の大事なお母様であって
お父さんであって 何の変わりもないと
だから動物を見る時でも形だけ見る
それって動物にとってすごい侮辱なんですよ
そちらも生き生きした生命ですからね
生命として見るべきなんですけど
我々はただ体だけ見るという世界では
そういう習慣もあります
よって 体でできることも変わります
まあ体が違いますから
体でできることも変わってますよ
よって 他人がやることは完全完璧に自分にはできない
だから 世の中で体中心に考えるんだから
人がやること自分もやりたがるんですね
テレビでも良い子は真似しないでくださいとか言わないと
頭のいい子だったら余計なことは真似しませんだけど
理性ある子だったら真似しませんよ
真似しようと思ったら
その子はもしかすると頑張ればできるかもしれませんしね
なんでそれに邪魔するのかわかりませんだけど
しかし 一般的に言えば
私たちに大きな問題があって
人が何かやると それも私もやりたいという気分になる
それはそれでいいかもしれませんだけど
同じ年齢だったらね しかし
まるっきり他人様のようにできるはずがないんです
肉体違いますからね もしかすると相手より下手かもしれません
あるいは相手より上手かもしれません
これわからないんです
ということは この他人より上手のまあ上手い場合も下手な場合もあります
誰かがすっごい素晴らしくピアノを弾いて
あ 私も弾きたいとかね
そう思わなくてもいいんです
誰がものすごい感動的に歌っていると
自分たちも一斉に もう喋るともう歌うと
あれ冗談じゃないんですけどね
だからもう別にできなくてもいいんです
体の調整についてはみんなよく知っている
それから この体だけは調整することは
皆様 体の能力は向上しなくちゃいけないんだと
体力つけなくちゃいけないんだということは知っている
ピアノを弾きたい人は
やっぱり体で覚えなくちゃいけないので
毎日 8時間  8時間訓練して訓練して
それは体で覚えたりする
それぐらいのことは私が喋らなくても知ってますから
もう省略します しかし
各体に調整できるリミットがあるので
あまりにも他人の体と比較しない方が良いのです
それだけ言っておきたいんです
体にはリミットがあるんです
だから  16歳で あるいは 14歳で世界一のピアニストになった子供がいるんだからといって
自分もそうなりますよと思ってもわかりませんね
なれるかならないかということは
そういうのはやっぱり体の筋肉の
神経の 脳の働きの問題だから
各体が違いますから 体には必ずリミットがあるんです
リミットは超えられません
それよく覚えた方がいいんです
で リミットがないのは心だけなんです
リミットがなく成長させることはできます
肉体はできません 例えば若い人と私が
ではもう二人でジョギングしようかなと思ったら
私の体にはリミットがありまして
200メートルぐらいで息切れちゃって
もう胸が痛くなっちゃって
そこで止まらなくちゃいけないんですよ
若者は 4 キロでも何のことなくジョギングしているかもしれません
だからってその子には 40キロできるかというと
そうじゃないんです 体にはリミットがあります
そのリミットもどんどん衰えてはいきます
しかし 体が衰えますから
得た能力も歳とともに衰えていくので気にしないこと
そんなのは一つ問題にしてはいけないと
もう無関心でへっちゃらでいいんです
誰かさんと比べると 自分がちょっと能力がないんだったら
別に体が違うんだから
自転車を漕いでみたら
もう友達がすごく足が速くて
自分がそんなにスピード出せないんだと
別にそれでいいんですよ
それぞれ体が違いますから
世の中で様々な これ間違ってますね
価値観ですけど なんで目になったんですかね
性格を理解しているんです
また同じことを繰り返しますけど
まああの 世の中の性格っていうのは
この自分の価値観であの見ることなんです
世界の価値観は論理的に具体的に定めたものではなく
なんとなく暗黙の了解で積み重ねたものです
世の中の価値観というのは
しっかりした研究の上で作った学問的なものじゃないんですよ
みんなそれぞれ価値観を持ってるでしょうし
なんででしょうかね わからないんですね
ただなんとなく積み重ねて積み重ねていきます
ですから 私は人を判断する基準というのは
いい加減で曖昧で中途半端で
あんまり当てにならないんですよ
ですから まず言いたいのは
世の中の人々 自分に対して言うことは真剣に受け止める必要はないんです
わかって言ってるわけじゃないんです
ただ 自分の感情で曖昧な価値観でガチャガチャガチャガチャ言ってるだけです
しかし 母親とかね 父親とかね
言うことはあまりに心配しているんだからね
耳をちょっとそろってあげた方がいいとは思います
各国の宗教や文化 時代
人の年 経済状態なども価値観を築くんですよ
それで人を判断する場合は
こういういろんなものをごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃで人を判断する
このような曖昧な価値観に基づいて人の性格を分析したり
良し悪しに判断したりするんです
で 我々はそうやって曖昧いい加減な判断をしています
この中から普遍的なところと言えるのは
この社会に対する対応の仕方でしょう
ちょっと難しいんですね
個人個人が社会に対してどんな対応をするべきかというところだけ
ちょっと普遍的なんですね
例えば まあよく謝るとかね
まあそれはヨーロッパでも日本語でもね
よくあることで ちょっと間違ったら
まあちょこっと謝ったりするとかね
そう そういうことをしない人はちょっとだらしないと
例えばごめんくださいと言わないで
いきなり人のドアを開けて入っちゃうと
性格悪いなと と判断してもしょうがないんです
これは社会の常識ですからね
私もそう判断するんです
ですから このイスラム教であろうが
キリスト教であろうが
日本であろうが関係なく
この社会の常識的な 社会に対する対応
そういうところの性格判断はまあ真剣に考えても構いません
例えばイスラム教でなくても
イスラムの国に行く女性は
まあ向こうの礼儀だから
何か体を隠しておく  で
ヨーロッパ人格だからといって日本の家に入る場合は靴を脱いでもらう
それでも脱いでくださいと言ったっても平気で
もう靴のまんまに畳の部屋に入ると
まあちょっと遠慮した方がいいんですね
そういう人々は性格的に問題ある
社会に対応適応しないわがままということになるんですね
人間は社会人なので この側面は無視できませんね
それで 世界にある性格分析の中で
仏教の目からまあ OK
マル入れるの そのセクションだけです
社会人としていかがなものでしょうかというところ
だから たとえ仏教徒であろうとも
友達が何か用事があって教会に行きますと言ったら
その教会 私は神様を信じてませんだからってこんな風にいるんじゃなくて
そちらの人々をやっているしきたり習慣をしてあげた方がお互い気分がいいんです
それは人格的にかなり要領があるという意味なんです
で そのところだけですね
それから決めつけてはならないという性格はね
自分で判断する自分の性格もあるし
他人が判断する自分の性格もあるし
性格 2つですよ 自分のことを他人が判断するし
自分のことを自分でも判断するんですね
まだ自分が判断する他人の性格もある
人の性格は他人の判断
自分の判断の間で動いているんです
これまだ俗世間の状態なんで
だから決めつけてはいけないんですね
自分が何者かと人は勝手に判断するし
自分でも自分が何者かと判断しているし
それでなんかちょっと定かでなくなっちゃうんですよ
自分がよく頑張ってるつもりですけど
周りがお前よく怠け者が怠け者が出てくると
あら どういうことかな？で
ちょっとなんか不安になっちゃうんですよ
だからこのわがままになっちゃうんですよ
時々いい 例えば私は親切じゃないということにしましょう
まあ本当は親切じゃないんですけどね
で 誰かがあんたって本当にすごく親切な人だなと言っちゃうと
あらと思っちゃう 思って親切なように振り回さなくちゃいけないという
本当は親切じゃないんだけど
もうこらえて親切に対応したりする
だからなんか自分でもわからなくなるでしょ
条件関係に応じて人は変わるので
性格は定めてない方が安全です
それで人間っていうのは
人間の性格っていうのは
瞬間瞬間変わるんですよ
皆様はこちらに座ってるんだからこの性格ですけど
外へ出たら何者かさっぱりわからないでしょうね
また家に戻ったら何者になる変身するかわからないんですよ
この環境によっての変わるんですよ
ですから 私はこんな性格だというふうに名刺は出せません
すごく会社で大人しく仕事をしている人を突然見て人殺して帰るってこともあるんだからね
それはわからないんです
環境によって変わるんです
ということで 我々は性格を決めつけることはできない
それで自己診断に行きます
基本的なとても高く評価したいんですね
自己診断の場合は それは性格のこと
ちょっとふざけて診断と言ったんですけど
別に判断ですけどね 自分で自分の性格を診断する場合は
まあ基本的に 100点満点入れたいんですよ
気持ちは しかし 周りの状況と比較して
満点から点数を減らす方法で価値をつけるんです
評価するんです 大体自己診断の場合は
まず自分に 100点満点あげるんです
そこで親がね 散々グタグタいろんなこと言われると
まあいいやででいくらか点数減らしちゃうんですね
そういえばそういうこともあるんだなとわかると
では 10点マイナスしようかなと
90点になっちゃうんですね
それで友達が間でいろんなこと言われたところで
やっぱりそうだとわかるで
じゃあまた 10点減らしてみようかな
と  80点になったりして
そんな感じで まあ自分の性格を判断するんです
点数で言えばわかりやすいだけで
点数つけるものじゃないんですけどね
客観性に欠けて余計に低く評価して落ち込む人もいるし
これは失敗作ですね 全く客観性に欠けちゃって
余計に自分のことを低く評価するというのは
これは性格には問題あるんですよ
それで落ち込んだりする
やっぱり私は何やってもダメだ
ダメな人間だとかね みんなにいろいろまあやっぱり言われるんだから
それはその通りやとかね
できっこはないんだとかね
これはもう治療を受けなくちゃいけないんです
妄想にふけって世界一だと評価する人もいるんですね
吾輩は世界一やという風に結構いますよ
私は神様だとかね 言ってる人いるでしょ
かなり病気なんですね
これは自己診断の問題なんです
だから この上行ったものをね
まあ私は私の性格は点数で言えば 100点満点なんですけど
それでお母さんはね あれこれって言うんだから
90点で それで先生によく叱られるし
やっぱり 80点でとかね
そうやって減らして減らして
まあどこかの点数になったら
これは普通な人間のやり方なんです
とにかく曖昧でしょ 自己診断は
自分でも自分の性格はわからないという方が合ってる事実なんです
正しく言うならば 私は私の性格はわかりませんと
曖昧で中途半端で その時その時変わるし
だからわかりません と言った方が正しいんです
人には自分の行動パターンに対しても自信があるとは言えないんですよ
我々の生き方ありますね
行動パターンというね
ライフスタイル それにも自信がないんですよ
私はずっとこの生き方で生きてやるぞということはね
例えばタバコを吸う人わけで
私はいくら何でもタバコはやめませんと
これは私のものすごい楽しみですよ
本当にそうなのかと もしかすると
ある日突然やめる可能性もある
あるいはタバコなんか絶対吸うもんかと思ってる人は
またある日見るとタバコをバクバク吸ってる可能性もある
ですから 自分の行動パターン
自分の生き方 私はよく頑張りますと
子供の頃からよく頑張りましたと
だから慣れたもんやということは
ちょっと言いにくいんですよ
で 私も昔はよくいろんな本を読んでいたんです
ところが このお寺で掃除したりすると
捨ててる新聞とか いろんなものを包装して持ってきて
あちこち捨ててあったりして
それを掃除しますよ その時全部拾って読むんです
まあ向こうはこの昔ですからね
このビニール袋では文化ではなかったんだから
店で買い物しちゃうと
子供たち書いて終わったノートとかね
その紙を破ってそこで包装してくれるんです
そういうものみたいに
私はこれ何書いているんでしょうかとかね
なんて言うんでしょうかとか
何から何まで読む癖があったんです
そこで意外といろんな情報が入るんですね
いろんなことを知ることになっちゃうんですね
で その癖はずっとありまして
もう何でも読んでみるというね
電車に乗ったら必ず今もやってますけど
新聞じゃなくて広告は全部読む
関係あってもなくても
で そういう性格やと思っきゃ
まあ後で読むのはものすごく嫌になっちゃったんです
何を読んだってくだらないんだと
なんの情報もないんだと
これでは智慧は開発しないんだと言って
完全に本読むことをやめちゃったんです
これが 15年 20  20年
そこそこもう続けてきて
また最近また読みだしちゃった
しかし テーマが違う 勉強のためには読まない
ただ 人間の文章の書き方
スタイル 表現力 単語の使い方
言いたいくだらんことをいかに美しく言うのかと
そのそこを楽しむために読んでます
だから人の性格って何やということは
そう決めるっていうことは難しいんですよ
飽きっぽい性格だという人も
すべてのものに対して飽きっぽいではありません
ということの一つの例だけなんですね
我々は勝手にあの人は飽きっぽいなと言っても
何でもかんでも飽きっぽいわけじゃないんです